der film heißt john wick teil 3
parabellum ist ein actionfilm von
schätzte heraus gibt es gibt kein
entkommen für dich die ruhe kammer will
der in cannes mit dem ehemaligen stank
mann der jetzt mit dieser reihe an
gefangenheit selbst regie zu führen
hauptdarsteller ist diane reeves und der
spielt einen auftragskiller der im
allerersten teil eigentlich aussteigen
wollte ganz klassische action story hat
aber seine frau gestorben und gangster
haben den kleinen hund den sie ihm
geschenkt hat umgebracht ich habe alles
verloren
der hund war das letzte geschenk meiner
verstorbenen frau also muss er rache
nehmen und geht wieder zurück da wo er
hergekommen ist diese ganze dunkle
unterwelt das war der erste teil im
zweiten kämpft er sich dann so ein
bisschen durch alles mögliche durch
bringt sehr sehr viele leute um unter
anderem den falschen deshalb jetzt im
dritten teil
alle gegen sich hat die gesamte welt die
gesamte unterwelt von new york es ist
eigentlich sehr sehr sehr schöne große
kugel 1
was ihn so besonders macht ist dass er
ganz anders an actionszenen angeht als
so ein normaler regisseur der davon
nicht so viel ahnung hat im interview
hat stets der health mir gesagt dass er
sehr großer fan von ballett ist das ein
sehr großer fan von klassischer musik
ist werden beides bei john wick 3 drin
nicht nur das ballett auch die
klassische musik also es wird hier ein
komplettes hotel foyer
auseinandergenommen das läuft dazu
vivaldi stehen mir eure dienstleistung
immer noch nicht zur verfügung was
brauchst du er dreht auch diese action
szenen sowie man normalerweise mit
waffen kann szene drehen würde also das
heißt die kamera ist immer an der
hauptfigur 3 und man weiß immer wo man
ist sie glauben sie können es mit johann
ruhig auf lehmann weiß immer warum kommt
jetzt hinter der säule jemand vor
sie werden eine böse überraschung
erleben es ist alles perfekt durchdacht
und sehr sehr logisch aufgebaut
ich wollte sie schon lange kennen lernen
und halten ihn eine ganz große nummer
eigentlich ist jetzt nur sehr viel da
chefs zu herzen nimmt sehr sehr viele
asiatische momente auf also er hat auch
mir selber gesagt dass er sehr sehr
großer fan des asiatischen kinos ist
also wenn man beispielsweise an filme
wie jackie chan filme denke man darf man
schon mal einen gesehen hat wo das
gesamte zimmer benutzt wird also man
weiß jeder einzelne stuhl der hier
irgendwo steht und jeder tisch der hier
steht wird irgendwann verwendet um
darüber zu rutschen unter zu rutschen
leute da auseinander zu nehmen damit
irgendwann wird der stuhl jemand um die
ohren
und genau so wendet der seine kamera
auch an genau so lässt er sich von von
räumen installiert spielen auf ewig
facetten anschauen sollten sich dass
leute die sowohl actionfilme natürlich
lieben motorräder lieben hunde lieben
alles komfort alles ist sehr sehr hübsch
gemacht aber auch leute die die auch
filme mit bisschen handlung stehen leute
die vielleicht gerne den james bond film
sehen woher auch relativ viel handlung
mit dabei ist und die es kaum erwarten
können nächsten james bond zu sehen und
gerne etwas haben wollen was ähnlich
qualitativ hochwertig ist und was
handlung mit action zusammen verbindet
und eine gute story macht nicht sehen
sollten das vielleicht leute die ein
bisschen empfindlich sind wenn es ein
bisschen zur sache gehen kann bei der
prügelei und all das geschieht war wegen
eines hundes
es war nicht nur ein hund für mich